what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation you're looking at the
three biggest Wonka fans right now
joined by John how are you I'm feeling
sweet koi unironically one of my most
anticipated of the Year koi when is our
Comic-Con panel that the real rejects is
having 1 p.m Saturday this July
something that's my second that's what
I'm talking about people wow looking at
what Timothy chalamet is wearing in this
thumbnail he is dressed like a sexy dog
I'm I'm transitioning to something guys
my feathered rejects today I've got a
tail waggingly good Scoop for you let's
talk about our sponsor bird dogs I'm
wearing them comfortable pants right now
but also they have their shorts that'll
have you looking fetching these shorts
are no bird brainers my friends let me
show you they're designed to fit Slimmer
through the thigh and the leg giving you
a truly possum sculpted look they do
everything Lululemon does but with an
extra wag in their tail so say goodbye
to those rough cotton shorts bird dogs
fix that Mudder by creating their Cloud
knit fabric I mean come on it looks as
sharp as khaki but stretches like a dog
chasing its tail you just gonna waste
them or fit without being you know leash
stricted got these puns going people
here's the cherry on top or should I say
the bird on the wire when you order from
bird dogs.com using my special code
rejects you'll fetch a free Yeti style
tumbler it's the perfect companion for
hydrating on your adventures
Grandpa's medicine so don't sit on the
perch my pals hurry over to birddogs.com
rejects to unleash the possum power of
these shorts and snag your free Yeti
style Tumblr trust me once you
experience the comfort and style you'll
be barking about bird dogs to all your
buddies they really are comfortable and
a lot of people want to know what are
some of the best ways to support the
channel one of the best ways to get
yourself some bird dogs by getting your
tail wagon head to birddogs.com rejects
now
I've spent the past seven years
traveling the world perfecting my craft
doing Australia something of a magician
inventor and chocolate maker so quiet up
and listen down nope scratch that
reverse it
is
what are you doing
I'm making chocolate of course how do
you like it dark white nutty absolutely
insane dark absolutely insane so
chocolate they've all been crushed by
the chocolate carts
and you can't sell chocolate without a
shop
[Music]
no daydreaming
huh
a double heart do the pencil on paper
uh-huh I got an idea
he's like the human Paddock didn't have
been easy for you they're gonna get
better you promise
I promise that's the most solemn vow
there is where do we
started
[Music]
what's happening oh that's a chocolate
that makes you fly let's find out shall
we who's forever John what's up that
Harry Potter touch burp Charlie small
group of people defined in the laws
what a cast and we had Olivia Coleman
earlier too
[Music]
about 150 pounds in the last two weeks
change her life
change all their lives
don't get visuals in here man yeah a
nice one started with a dream
it's a world of Pure Imagination you
hold on to yours yeah there we go mama
mark my words this is gonna be the
greatest chocolate shop the world has
ever seen
all right shell made a funny little man
there he is
no there he is foreign
oh that's hilarious you know I gotta say
I gotta say that kind of looks like you
know when Disney was doing those live
action sequels or prequels it kind of
looked like that but with the production
quality of a Harry Potter film and I
feel like chalamet is probably going to
do a pretty good job I mean he seems
like he's doing a bit of a hybrid blend
of what what Johnny Depp did in Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory and from the
clips I've seen of Gene Wilder I've
never actually seen the Willy Wonka
movie if that's a fun fact about Greg
never saw that one so yeah I mean I
thought this was a fun trailer this was
nice based off of your reaction I feel
like you actually know this
I mean yeah I'm I'm cautiously
optimistic about this this was I thought
this was a solid first trailer this
doesn't like I grew up with the movie I
grew up with the book I saw the Johnny
Depp one at some point so he knows it
too yeah so yeah I'll cover Ahsoka later
yeah this is certainly going for
something you know obviously sweet and
heartwarming and you know it's telling
that they got the Paddington director I
associate Roald Dahl with a certain
amount of like Rye orneryness that I'm
curious to see how and if they will
incorporate so much into this movie
because I know they've said they want
this to be like you know a warm and
uplifting film and it's like a full-on
musical
um so yeah this is like actually a
little bit more centered in like you
know the cartel and in the city than I
expected I I thought they would lead
more with like just full-on
swashbuckling Adventure or whatever but
it it certainly got me consciously
optimistic I like the production values
and the costumes and the look of
everything
koi please Paddington one and two are
two of the rare five star films of my
heart I've ever seen them koi never seen
the paddingtons I'm missing out on a lot
of these things wow paddington's forever
I've said it before and I'll say it
again I've ridden 4 000 films I've given
23 5 star two of them are Pat I've got
some movies to add to my reactions
Paddington I I truly feel are two of the
most heartwarming films of all time so
this was really high up in my most
anticipated list because it does look
like it's Timothy Charlemagne as the
Paddington character like he's he's got
that Whimsy he's got that heart he's got
that wonder he's got that like
splendiferous sense of awe but you add
you juxtapose perhaps you have some
dichotomy Duality uh with Roald Dahl's
Darkness it's duplicitousness of the
Roald Dahl Paddington dichotomy is
really what intrigues me but I I really
think that Roald Dahl's cantankerousness
is so wonderful and there's something
that makes you laugh while you're like
man this is dark that I think is really
unique specifically to Willy Wonka in
the Chocolate Factory so I love the idea
of Like An Origin before he kills all
those kids so I think it's going to be a
really fun movie they're not alive
anymore because of things he said those
kids aren't not murdered
children so I think this looks really
sweet and wonderful and then I I do
agree there was a lot of the Harry
Potter
um sense of scope and sense of awe so I
really it looks like a greatest hits for
that really warm feeling you want over
the holidays this being the Christmas
movie of the year it feels like I mean
I'd rather have this be the new Harry
Potter than rehashing Harry Potter this
looks great to me what I was kind of
craving from this trailer though because
yeah you want to reintroduce into the
world you want to show you want to give
a good visual sense of the tone and the
aura and the mood I want to get a little
bit more of the musical inclinations
though that they were hinting at I
wanted to kind of get a tease of what
you know Timothy chalamet's voice might
ultimately sound like what he's saying
I'm not has he done a musical before I'm
not familiar I think that's my knowledge
does he sing the Army Hammer and call me
by your name yeah
each um but what I also really wanted is
to sort of get this sense of like
rooting for for Wonka since this is
supposed to be because in the in the
Willy Wonka story you know he is the
mysterious figure who knows more than
everyone else and then you're finding
out what his master plan is as you
slowly uncover some of his backstory
right and then here I wanted to kind of
get a sense of like I want to see some
of that weird eccentricity in the the
awkwardness and some of the troubling
upbringing that the guy had as well but
get a sense of like really rooting for
him since he is the main character we're
going to root for this time you know and
but right now it's the first trailer and
as the first trailer goes uh I thought
it was Charming it was delightful what
did you guys think about chalamet's
first look do you think he's gonna live
up to the Wilder do you think he's gonna
live up to the depth chewing gum is
really aggressive
depths the wildness of Wilder the
chalamet peaches leave your thoughts
down below people well leave a like
subscribe keep a lookout for a Comic-Con
panel if you're going to Comic Con well
let's end this with a
I wanted to shout out Andrew Hayes
Andrew if there's someone I would love
to Delight in eating a bunch of
chocolate with I feel like it would be
you man there's just something about you
where you're already kind of like a
squirrely little guy and I think that if
we were just getting a sugar rush
together it could just escalate into
like the most semi cocaine filled kind
of conversations but just rooted in
sugar and all kinds of high you know
fructose corn syrup type of neurotic
conversations that I feel like we could
really have together so Andrew I hope
that the next time you're out in
California it's around Halloween time so
we could just get all sugary Goods up in
this hizzy my friend I love you thank
you for never unpleasing thank you for
never sending us any messages in the
past couple years and you've been one of
our highest pledges since I'm pretty
sure your card is just on auto repeat
every month and you have no idea I hope
it's your parents credit card and I love
that about you my friend we'll talk soon
[Music]